seacrest county has become the ultimate
place to speed a playground for the most
exotic cars and drivers in the world but
this is not a lawless place constant
competition has led to the creation of
the world's fastest policing seacrest
county speed enforcement the scpd spare
no expense to redline it all the way and
make you pay every day new drivers still
show up and attempt to tame sucress
county and outrun the law
the pursuit for the ultimate drive
starts here which side are you on
[Music]
entry in the roadster's reborn race
event is confirmed
in this showcase event you will unleash
the true potential of the roadster as
you compete against other drivers in a
race along the seacrest county coast use
your driving skills to outmaneuver the
opposition and take a medal your
reputation is measured in wanted levels
currently you are not registering much
activity and are classed by the scpd as
a level 1 speeder
the greatest drivers win the races and
outrun the law with style and are
classified as level 20 most wanted
your daily activity is measured as
bounty the harder faster and more
dangerously you drive the more bounty
you will earn
win races beat your rivals and stay one
step ahead of the cops to increase your
wanted level and get access to new cars
and entry into the toughest events
your car is equipped with a race spec
nitro system
use this system to gain a rapid
acceleration increase nitrous will only
charge if you drive dangerously drive in
oncoming traffic lanes near miss other
vehicles drift corners and take
shortcuts to gain the most nitrous
this race has restricted entry
requirements you can choose any of the
available cars to drive in the race some
cars are locked at this
porsche engineers have realized a
long-held dream the dream of a roadster
that is more original more sporty
[Music]
[Music]
welcome cadet you have been accepted
into the ranks of the scpd the world's
fastest speed enforcement units you
begin your career as a rank one cadet
with limited access to the department
the pinnacle of the speed enforcement
unit are the rank 20 ultimate enforcers
with access to any vehicle or pursuit
resource required
your career with the scpd will be
measured on your performance in the
field all of your actions are monitored
and recorded in the system as bounty the
more bounty you are awarded during an
active mission the faster you will
progress
today you will be driving the ford cram
victoria as you prove your value to the
department command will make more exotic
equipment available to you good luck
on three points
standing down over to you
suspect heavy damage
target has been apprehended all units
[Applause]
so
foreign
[Music]
situation on mission b
i've made contact
so
final warning
foreign
headed on sunset drive
[Applause]
i'm taking damage
suspects are now under arrest for
processing
[Music]
the dodge charger name is a historical
one associated with performance with
core door flexibility
[Music]
uh
i'll start back
really
oh
let's see how he responds
dc
so
suspect
it's so big to hit it on road
he's not going over
with caution
so
[Music]
you